california's salton sea shimmers like a
mirage in an arid land but its waters
are nearly lifeless full of salt and
agricultural chemical runoff the farming
communities near the sea are among the
poorest in the u.s with high
unemployment and nearly one in four
people living in poverty frank salazar
is a local resident and activist what we
lack is opportunity you know i think
opportunity is what we need here in this
in this county the salton sea is
shrinking as streams are diverted to
farming on windy days toxic dust from
the dry lake shore fouls the air we look
at the asthma levels of our local
children when you look at the cancer
levels of our local residents they're
through the roof but far below the sea's
floor lies a vast reservoir of
superheated water rich in lithium the
element used to create batteries for
electric vehicles and a key to slowing
global warming we have what some have
described as the saudi arabia of lithium
here in the state of california the
stakes are high not only for the
region's future prosperity but for u.s
national security the u.s wants a
domestic supply of lithium today more
than 80 percent of all lithium is mined
in australia chile and china but the
salton seas treasure trove of the
mineral could change those numbers
dramatically we expect
to produce about a third of global
lithium from this site it's an
incredible resource companies are
already drilling what you see in the
background there are two production
wells full diameter wells that will
produce enormous amounts of brine to
feed the plant that which will be
located here state and local officials
envision a lithium-based industrial
complex with battery factories and
electric car manufacturing well-paying
jobs with benefits that currently aren't
here in imperial county i salivate when
i think about it five ten years down the
road how big it can be conservationists
like eileen anderson approve of the
environmentally friendly extraction
process powered by geothermal energy
they hope lithium projects will generate
funds to restore the salt and sea which
is a crucial stopover point for
migrating birds and she's looking at the
big picture if we're going to transition
to clean energy and get off our fossil
fuel addiction
lithium is going to be a key component
hope for a region down on its luck and a
planet heating up
rob reynolds al jazeera imperial
california
let's bring in jan wang who is a
professor of mechanical engineering at
worchester polytechnic institute in
massachusetts he joins us live now
thanks for being on this newshour jan
why is lithium so important particularly
in the battle against climate change
so because lithium is the k element for
lithium batteries we know lithium
batteries is widely used for
part of electronics electric cars and
the grid storage
let's buy less there
we need lithium in order to make lithium
lithium-ion batteries
professor
you mentioned batteries that lithium is
used for batteries but what other
potentials does it have
and
lithium has other applications but right
now like uh people are buying like
lithium-ion batteries will be widely
used like electric cars that's a huge
market you see like all the news from
major car companies right so they
announced by 2030 2035
all the car will be made by
it will be powered by lithium-ion
batteries that's a huge market huge
potential for the lithium
and so can those batteries then be
recycled what impacts are there on the
environment using lithium
and right now like uh
people are starting thinking about
lithium battery recycling and consider
as limited resource and also like uh
it's hard to mine loads of lithium from
either
from from lithium
mining so recycling lithium batteries is
critical for sustainable industry
and also in addition to
recycling i think
we also need to think about developing
other types of batteries like sodium ion
batteries is i think it's also important
professor what are some of the other
challenges in lithium becoming a
sustainable industry
not just the recycling i think like
i think how to mine the lithium more
efficiently and
also lower cost
and
that's also probably important
and i still think that recycling is a
key piece of puzzle in order to enable
the industry sustainability because like
as i said like lithium
there's an only limited resource for
luther it's also mainly mined in a few
countries like australia chile china
argentina
and
so imagine like uh for example u.s u.s
like uh produced roughly 10 percent off
for lithium batteries but we don't mind
lithium here so that's why like you use
a lot of lithium but you don't produce
any leaf here so that means you have to
recycle those spanned batteries like
in addition like uh uh based on some
report by 2020
2015 if people don't recycle
lithium there's not enough lithium for
the for the for the industry mainly
driven by the electric vehicle industry
well it certainly is a growing industry
and we appreciate your insights thank
you very much yan wang a professor of
mechanical engineering appreciate your
time
thank you